ce soir le bilan de raymond barre après
son élection le maire de lyon avait pris
son temps neuf mois avant de proposer
son plan de mandat frank giroud à
rechercher dans nos archives certains
projets ont été réalisés d'autres sont
en chantier et servent de base aux
programmes des principaux candidats à sa
succession
ils ont à la barre un mandat unique est
suffisant pour laisser sa trace dans une
ville comme lyon 8 ans dépendra sans
doute à cette question coup de
projecteur sur des morceaux choisis de
ce mandat
d'abord une action à vaise pour que le
9e arrondissement change le visage dans
ce 9e arrondissement de quartier ont été
remodelées celui de la toute nouvelle
médiathèque et le quartier de
l'industrie future silicon valley de
saône avec l'installation du siège
mondial d'infogrames un coup de pouce de
l'amérique centrale au maire socialiste
de l'arrondissement bon point pour le 9e
et le 8e arrondissement qui rattrapent
leur retard tandis que le premier des
pentes de la croix-rousse marque le pas
deuxièmement gerland de manière en faire
un peu scientifique de développement et
un boulevard scientifique là il
s'agissait de donner un coup
d'accélérateur au sud de la ville dans
le domaine de l'industrie et de la
recherche scientifique
l'inauguration du laboratoire p4
laboratoire de recherche sur les virus
dangereux en est sans aucun doute le
symbole vous êtes tout comme
l'installation de l'école normale
supérieure lettres ouvertes lors de la
dernière rentrée universitaire ce
quartier de gerland accueille désormais
à nouveau parc de loisirs le long du
rhône juste en face du fameux confluent
grand projet qui relève pour l'instant
plus du domaine de l'utopie que de la
réalisation
j'espère obtenir l'appui de l'état pour
engager le contournement autoroutier
ouest
ce qui permettra
aux mandature suivante de raser perrache
mais là c'est un peu la panne
les contournements autoroutiers et
routiers de lyon n'ont pas porté chance
à raymond barre souvenez-vous de
l'inauguration de théo en juillet 1997
le célèbre tronçon du périphérique nord
est est un héritage de la période michel
noir la mise en service de ce tronçon à
péage avait fait débat en chat qui me
concerne je pense qu'il faut maintenir
aujourd'hui ce tronçon et son péage
semble digérée par les automobilistes et
des contribuables mais cette polémique a
eu comme effet d'enterrer le dossier de
bouclage du périphérique dans sa partie
ouest à propose deux modes de transport
raymond barre laissera un souvenir au
lyonnais l'a remis sur rails d'un
tramway de ligne qui relie les campus
universitaires à la gare de perrache le
tramway et non le prolongement du métro
par souci d'économie et pour en finir
avec les équipements de la ville dans le
domaine culturel l'ancienne caserne des
subsistances entièrement rénové vient
d'être livré aux mains des artistes pour
que leur création puisse s'exprimer
enfin l'image de la ville a changé de
couleur son centre historique est
désormais inscrit au patrimoine mondial
de l'unesco
certains touristes un peu particulier
sont passés par là à l'occasion de
grandes réunions au sommet comme le
gessien en présentant son plan demande à
raymond barre l'avait dit pas de
paillettes de la rigueur demain il
quittera ses fonctions il laissera un
héritage mais pas d'héritier désignait
la plus haute fonction municipale aux
lyonnais maintenant de juger pas
oh